let's pull up some of this weird this
this this uh absurdity oddity
shady dealings weirdity so we have this
tweet from alwaleed talal
he says i don't believe that the
proposed offer by elon musk 54.20 comes
close to the intrinsic value of twitter
given its growth prospects being one of
the largest and long-term shareholders
of twitter kingdom khc and i reject this
offer
let me elon musk responded to this in a
very powerful way but the first thing i
want to do is give you some context in a
story from from reuters published by
yahoo finance they say something very
simple let me uh scroll down
serial under performer twitter's lower
than expected user editions in recent
months have raised doubts about its
growth prospects even as it pursues big
projects such as audio chat room chat
rooms and newsletters yes
anybody who knows anything knows that
twitter has constantly struggled that's
right so so what about elon musk's
premium offer as a bad deal well for for
the prince in saudi arabia maybe it is a
bad deal elon musk responded interesting
just two questions if i may how much of
twitter does the kingdom own directly
and indirectly what are the kingdom's
views on journalistic freedom of speech
elon musk is a brave man in going after
some of the biggest companies and
political uh uh you know leaders in the
world
but he makes a really good point and
i'll throw back the point i made earlier
i believe the prince uh all the lead is
correct fifty four dollars and twenty
cents doesn't come close to the true
value of twitter which is controlling
the american news cycle especially if
you're dependent upon the united states
for weapons and you like a lot of the us
foreign interests when it comes to
destabilizing the region no it's true
and so people talk about the fact that
jeff bezos owns the washington post and
it's definitely very funny there's a lot
of great memes that have come out out of
that but elon musk owning twitter would
obviously make him significantly more
powerful than any billionaire who
happens to own a single publication well
this is also how elon musk i think makes
almost all of his decisions he thinks
what is jeff bezos doing how can i do it
better that's his actual
oh you may oh you make phallic rocket
ships that's that's cute bezos
i'll i'll take us to mars i think
before the show you made it you framed
it the best way possible you know so who
was it was you michael who said or maybe
sheamus elon musk is the first rich
person is something cool with their
money yeah that's not an original
thought from myself i think it might
have been cerno who said that but then
you said jeff bezos
how did you frame it oh uh uh jeff bezos
does
some i don't know he does cool things
and makes him uncool
no you said he's he's interesting as a
boring person yeah he's like yeah
something like that and his rocket ship
looks like a penis
i mean it was really really good too
it's like it's like oh man it's not the
greatest joke ever but if only you were
there you would have heard it right
interesting in the way a boring person
is basically yeah you said in a way a
boring person is like he makes a rocket
but it's not cool yeah yeah
it looks like a penis as you see elon
and jeff were on twitter talking back
and forth about the home turning twitter
headquarters into a homeless shelter and
uh basil's like actually it's a great
idea we converted half of the amazon i
don't headquarters or something into a
homeless shelter and that the employees
can volunteer and you know what's
interesting the best part about uncool
it's like it's like
the way that this has become a very
hostile takeover kind of situation what
i love about it is every time elon does
something new and he's rebuffed but
whether it's by the saudis or whether
it's by the board or pariah aggro wall
they say okay they got elon now uh too
bad it was good
as if elon just woke up one day and said
hey bye bye bye bye you know it's hard
to buy nine percent of twitter you know
you kind of have a plan going into it
and you don't become the richest guy on
earth
on accident you know you generally
speaking you're pretty smart about these
things and elon not forget about plan b
that he talked about today
i bet you he's got plan c and d and ian
who's this engineer that's what they do
this is the intention the ultimate thing
about elon musk that i've been saying
for a long time he's the greatest living
american he is the only he is the only
person i'm right
he's the only person on earth right now
with a positive vision for the future of
humanity that actually involves you know
the dignity of the individual it
actually involves freedom uh and and
it's and it's constructive he's not a
guy who's lamenting the past he's not a
guy who thinks it's all over he doesn't
believe we're at the end of history he's
a guy who's like let's make things
cooler than anybody's ever made them
let's go further than anybody's ever
gone let's go faster the the greatest
answer maybe in the history of well the
greatest answer in the history of media
is when larry king asked vice president
dick cheney if we should bomb iran and
dick cheney said
for
what
the second best answer in the history of
media is when jay leno was trying to jab
at elon musk for putting bulletproof
windows on the cyber truck and he's like
why why would you do that
and elon said
because it's badass
is it you know what you know what i like
about elon musk all of those things you
mentioned but he
54 and 20 cents everybody's saying he
just want to put 420 in that yeah he
wanted that to be in the news i bet he
did he posted he posted the next twitter
board meeting is going to be lit and
it's him smoking pot
he's just he's having fun because it's
always like ben franklin man better like
make the turkey our national bird the
ultimate troll until elon i think people
like turkeys i love turkeys yeah but i'm
also i don't know about trolling i think
i will say that
god kings don't look up to many folk
but i will say that everything we do at
the daily wire is basically trying to uh
to emulate this kind of an attitude to
say that our best days are ahead of us
we can build alternatives we can do good
things we don't have to just sit in a
state of perpetual grief because things
aren't as aren't the way that they used
to be that we can take the great ideas
of the past and build better things atop
them
even the same kind of financial pardon
my bluntness stupidity you could just
take your money and run you could run
right now and have a good life and you
stupidly have reinvested your money and
are building all these new companies
what an idiot certain kind of stupidness
putting money into doing good stuff
buying twitter oh man you know but the
funny thing is there that most rich
people feel that way and that freaks me
out
i want to give a shout out to elon
because um
everything he's doing i i'm inspired by
and i i'm somebody who grew up with no
heroes i mean their pro skateboarders
are like that was a great trick but i
never looked at anybody and said i want
to do that and now i'm watching
everything he's doing and he's like and
i'm just like i need 300 billion dollars
so i can buy twitter too so like so i
can so i can shake things up i once
tweeted at elon musk why haven't you
built an iron man suit yet and he
responded building starship and i was
like
that's an acceptance
yes yes that is so weird about him is
that politically he's got generally the
right ideas because all these guys look
i don't care about cars i really don't
care about electric cars i don't care
about going to space i never watched
star i swatched star wars not star trek
i just don't shame on you i know i know
everyone knocks i don't care like none
of that interests me whatsoever but you
know what i do care about
uh my republic and my government and my
politics and all these futurist guys are
always lunatics all these billionaire
masters of the universe always want to
enslave all of us and put us in a prison
colony on mars and he's the one dude
who's saying no i actually want you to
have your traditional way of life and
your freedom or at a minimum he's who
the government will have to pay to get
to the prison colonies
that's the long game oh he is
african-american he's from south america
so do you guys think south africa so do
you guys think that we should at some
point maybe amend the constitution so a
non-american citizen can run for
president well at least an
african-american like elon musk well the
question is do you really think elon
musk would do more good as president as
opposed to what he's doing now no way
yeah not unless he owns twitter well and
i'll say this i haven't really paid
close attention to them not enough
attention to say i
am a huge fan but stuff like this really
makes me like him what i really
appreciate is the fact that he is
countering the overpopulation narrative
we were discussing this before the show
a little bit he says that we're not
going to have another enough people that
underpopulation is going to be a serious
problem he's absolutely correct and how
unbelievably refreshing it is to have an
elite who isn't misanthropic who doesn't
say human life is fundamentally bad or
at the very least needs to be mitigated
in some shout out to elon's mom dude
that woman is amazing but you know while
we're all uh uh getting ready to uh uh
well i'll keep it family friendly and
just say pat him on the back only for
only to end world hunger
i would only ever do this maybe but but
there are questions about his his
statements on china sure uh so i could
be wrong but wasn't he going on like
chinese social media and praising the
chinese communist party or something to
that effect and that's if that's the
case that's very difficult could be
wrong i don't want to you know call up
the dude who i think is doing rad stuff
but you know part of me is concerned
like
maybe the dude's got a big play to make
a bunch of money and he's just it's it's
still flipping the bird to the system
which i can respect but is is the end
goal like you mentioned here's what he
does he tanks the company he buys it he
turns it private changes some rules
lists it makes a quick billion but
that's not a bad thing first of all
elon musk doesn't need money he's the
richest person not only in the world but
in the history of the world even when we
talk about the 280 some billion dollars
of net worth that he has you have to
keep in mind
spacex hasn't had a public offering so
we're not we're not really contemplating
any of the value that exists in the only
access that the united states has to
space uh neurolink is probably only just
getting started hasn't gone public we've
never seen in our life not since
rockefeller have we seen a figure like
elon musk the guy very likely could be
the first trillionaire to walk the earth
so we can't even really contemplate the
amount of money that elon musk
represents so listen everybody likes to
make a quick billion uh but elon musk
isn't there's there's just no way that
he's motivated in this by that the what
more what i'm saying is that the
positive aspect of economic incentive
is that it allows you to do good and do
well and so i think that elon musk is
doing a good thing missionally with what
he's doing with faith with twitter and
he will also likely make a lot of money
i i don't see those two things being in
uh so the fear is within the metaverse
and with neuralink is someone like
zuckerberg being in charge and letting
him get access to your brain
would you go into the metaverse via a
neural link if it was elon musk who was
the you know god king of the metaverse
no i don't
he's saying he's going to open source
the code of twitter the algorithm which
is the first step to trusting the device
or the software you're using if you can
reference the algorithm see if it's
spying on you or not if you have a
device that lets you enter the metaverse
and it's not spying on you that's the
only way to go yeah and so you you
mentioned uh some statements that he
ostensibly made about china this is also
part of why i'm i'm sort of withholding
a little bit i don't know a huge amount
about the guy but part of part of the
reason i was making the point that i
made is because it is really disturbing
that the fact that he is against the
overpopulation narrative it's very
disturbing that that sets him apart from
virtually everyone else in power but i
also think that speaks to what you're
discussing which is this idea of being
optimistic and having a plan for the
future i think misanthropy is the
greatest indicator that a person doesn't
have a plan for the future and they're
just a horrifically jaded pessimist
listen the the other aspect of this is
that he's probably wrong about china
and maybe isn't a great dad i i don't
know maybe he's a great dad i don't i'm
only saying elon musk is a human being
and all of sin and fall short of the
glory of god and it's not what is
common about us
that is noteworthy definitionally it's
what's noteworthy about us that's
noteworthy and so i think about like
george washington right never says oh
george washington owned slaves i'm like
yeah he was a a planter in virginia in
the uh 18th century they all own slaves
that's what's average about him that's
not notable about him at all in his time
and in his place what's notable about
him among other things is that he freed
his slaves none of the rest of them did
so that does that justify slavery no is
that an excuse for slavery no it's only
to say that it's not worth bringing up
that george washington owned slaves
that's not actually an interesting thing
about george washington in his time he
owned 300 slaves and it was not
interesting about him if i owned even
one slave it would be remarkably
noteworthy because in my time and in my
place that would be the incredibly
strange peculiar thing that reveals
something about me and so for a
billionaire uh industrialist
to uh believe in free trade and be
dependent somewhat on um the mar the
chin the asian markets and probably on
chinese manufacturing elon musk isn't
who outsourced all of america's
manufacturing that happened 50 years ago
60 years ago but he is amen
he is dependent in many ways on that
manufacturing uh although he's doing
something about it and trying to
manufacture in america but all that to
say
those aren't actually the interesting
things about them there may be negative
things about him but they're not
noteworthy things about him what's
noteworthy about him is that he's the
only guy in that space who to your point
seems to be pro-human he's the only
person in that space who seems to be
pro-speech these are the actual
noteworthy the pro-human thing part is
so important because it is the weirdest
aspect to me especially if bill gates
bill gates will not shut up about how
there are too many people on the planet
and it's just a lie overpopulation is
completely made up
most notably there was this book the
population bomb in 1970-71
it said that within 10 years even if we
now coerce abortions which the book
called for it coerced sterility even if
we do that right now we're screwed
there's going to be 10 in 10 years mass
famine everywhere and it was completely
made up where 50 years later the world
population doubled malnutrition is at an
all-time low thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you